foreign
[Music]
I'm excited to be speaking at the 2022
lab Roots laboratory automation seminar
my name is Dr Christine Pasco I'm a
senior VP here at accelerated technology
Laboratories and today we're going to be
talking about limbs laboratory
Automation and data integrity
today we're going to cover a few
learning objectives the first is going
to deal with the importance of data
Integrity the second we'll deal with the
acronym Alcoa as well as Alcoa plus and
the role that limbs plays in
facilitating compliance with Alcoa and
then also we'll have a discussion on the
entire solution and the entire system
the role that different elements play
from the quality management management
system to limbs to automation to ensure
that Laboratories generate data with
high data integrity
okay let's take a quick look at our
agenda for today we're going to discuss
what value a limbs offers the laboratory
is along with automation
what is data Integrity what defines good
data quality we'll look at the life
cycle of data and then also compliance
and non-compliance and we'll also take a
look at a few case studies
now if we look at this slide it's
basically basically depicting a
laboratory information management system
along with all the components
integration with different
instrumentation in the laboratory
integration with Enterprise Solutions
CDs Solutions the ability to
automatically schedule sample polls
whether it's a stability study a shelf
life study being able to generate
automated reports where the data is very
easy to interpret the QC is contained
within the report looking at metrics
warning if the temperature of the
freezer is below limit being able to
automatically generate labels
and also securely being able to access
that data in remote locations to
increase communication throughout the
organization so think of a limbs as
really a the heartbeat of the laboratory
now if we look at the data life cycle
you know it begins with a plan whether
it's an experimental plan an r d plan a
work plan so you're defining what data
you'll be collecting and then you
actually go and acquire the data whether
it's manual readings or it's data that
is supplied from another system and
imported or if you're acquiring it from
an instrument
often instruments are real very prolific
in their output so those instruments
really make sense to interface and then
you have to maintain that data to make
sure that it is backed up regularly and
often times off-site as well in the
event that there's a fire or something
at the facility you want to make sure
that that data is accessible by those
people that need to have access to it so
with Privileges and permissions the
users can have different roles they can
access the data that they need and then
finally the ability to evaluate that
data so being able to look at um
different types of charts and graphs and
statistics on that data and then finally
when the data has been evaluated to be
able to Archive that data in the event
that you need to access that in the
future
and then this is all
um with maintaining good quality
assurance and quality control
one very popular automation tool is
positive ID barcodes as well as RFID and
you can see the difference between
one-dimensional barcodes as well as
two-dimensional which can hold much more
information as well as radio frequency
ID solutions that are ideal for
applications where you have a high
number of
sample so that you need to scan and you
don't have direct access to them
instrument integration is another tool
that saves laboratory significant time
and also increases the throughput it
doesn't it eliminates the need for
having scientists re-key in data so it
eliminates transcription errors it
increases the time to result the return
on investment is typically 9 to 12
months the most modern instruments can
also receive a work list from the limbs
so the samples can be organized in the
limbs with all the QC inserted that work
list can be exported to the instrument
the instrument can run the samples and
then once the run is completed it can
send the results back to the limbs and
it also results in higher employee
satisfaction because analysts don't have
to spend time cutting in pasting or
re-keying in data
how does it work basically the output
file whether it's a comma separated
value an Excel file a text or ASCII or
XML or something else is sent over and
then a parser is created which places
the code in the format that the lens is
looking for you can also pull in other
types of information whether it's from a
subcontracted lab so that all the data
is in the database and then there's an
error log for anything that didn't
import properly so that the limbs
administrator can take a look and see
what went wrong you can also use work
list with barcodes to quickly
import the work List information so
there's a lot of different ways that
barcodes can be leveraged in the
laboratory
Laboratories are in business to generate
data accurate precise reproducible data
the next few slides we're going to be
talking about data integrity
data Integrity can be thought of as a
state or process if we look at the
process it describes all the measures
that are put in place to ensure that
data is valid and accurate so all the
components of that data set in a
database are valid and accurate and this
applies to things such as the standards
that are used in in the controls that
are used in analyzing specific samples
so that you can trace that sample back
to the exact Lot number of the control
that was used as well as error checking
and validation methods making sure that
the data Integrity processes are in
place
a date Integrity is a state it defines a
data set that's both valid and accurate
now if we take a closer look at the
process it refers to domain Integrity
where the constraint is on the
individual value in the SQL database so
check constraints entity Integrity
looking at the entire table with primary
keys and unique constraints referential
Integrity the data must exist in other
table you have foreign keys and the
whole goal is to avoid bad data which is
you know data that's duplicated missing
inaccurate or incorrect
now if we take a look at data Integrity
as a state this involves things such as
technical controls procedural controls
such as standard operating procedures
that are often referred to as work
instructions these can also be linked in
the limbs for ready access
extensive use of sensors an example
would be temperature monitoring for your
refrigerators freezers incubators so
that you have up-to-date information by
the minute of the health of that
equipment
integration with different
instrumentation
such as the icpms the GCS
a variety of instruments and then also
Enterprise Integration so this could be
with the CRM it could be with sap an
accounting package making sure employees
are trained as well as subject matter
experts so that you have on file copies
of resumes training certificates that
they've obtained through completing
various trainings whether it's safety
training fire safety training lab safety
training being able to attach those
training records in the limbs so that
when an auditor asks for proof of that
training it's readily accessible having
a company culture that supports quality
Kappa corrective and preventative
actions and making sure that there's
buy-in for management as well as support
all right what is Alcoa many of you may
have heard of This Acronym it stands for
various characteristics of good data
it's attributable it's um it's been
documented who acquired the data who
entered or wrote it and when date and
time stamps and the limbs or other
electronic system
is it legible can you read and
understand the data and information
is it contemporaneous were the records
documented at the time of the activity
is it original is it the first recorded
observation
is it accurate is the result
scientifically valid and error-free so
these are the components that make up
Alcoa
now what is Alcoa plus we've heard of
the first five Alcoa now Alcoa Plus
adds a few actually Four additional
characteristics complete it means that
all the data including any repre repeat
or re-analysis performed are included
it's consistent all the elements of the
analysis as well as date and time stamps
are in the correct sequence it's
enduring that data is recorded as
permanent it's maintainable throughout
its life cycle and finally that it's
available and basically that is ready
for review inspection or audit as long
as the record exists so this plus
encompasses these four additional
characteristics
now we've learned what Alcoa plus is now
what happens when there's a violation in
data Integrity if we take a look at root
causes of data Integrity issues some of
them include performance and business
pressure oftentimes organizations have
invested a lot of time and money in the
creation of certain products and when
they find a problem they make a decision
should we just ship anyway or should we
correct the problem and oftentimes you
know higher profits and cost pressure
wins over you know safety so it's
interesting later on we'll look at a few
case studies where there have been
violations in Alcoa also it could be a
lack of awareness or capability you know
if the analysts that are working in the
laboratory are poorly trained and
they're not sure what the correct sop
they should follow is or maybe there are
no Sops or poorly written Sops so
training and capability what if the
organization doesn't have a culture of
data Integrity there's maybe poor
communication of raw material problems
among workers maybe there's High
turnover the operating procedures are
inconsistent aren't regularly updated so
if the organization doesn't make data
Integrity a focus in their in their
management principles it may not trickle
down to the entire team
and then finally if there's inadequate
process and processes and technology so
if there aren't any computerized systems
with adequate training that people can
utilize to record their data or if there
are no Sops to be followed that are
updated there are no training records
that the the processes have been trained
on so here's just a few examples and
it's interesting that in 80 percent of
the cases where there are data Integrity
issues it is due to unintentional action
so only 20 percent are per on purpose
now if we take a look at how we can
address data Integrity issues
the best is through education and
communication understanding and
detecting risk defining a strategy for
data integrity and Technology within the
organization and then finally
establishing a governance structure for
data Integrity so it really has to do
with many different components of
ensuring there's High data quality
generated in the organization
now if we take a look at some
compromises in data Integrity how do
these occur well it can be human error
it can be transfer errors if people are
cutting and pasting or it could be
accidental changing of numbers if
they're in a read only if they're in a
um if they're in a mode where they can
accidentally hit the keyboard and change
a value it could be due to bugs or
viruses or other cyber threats it could
be a disk crash or other Hardware
failure since some of the compromises
can be prevented through data security
there's a strong case for backing up
data the minute it's generated so that
if you do have a data loss you can go to
your backup and retrieve that data
um also input validation to make sure
that invalid data isn't entered so
catching the data up front is is really
wise and an example of this is if you
have a pH value for example and you set
the field to not allow any pH over 14.
so you might say you know the pH is
between this value and this value so if
someone tries to type in a 41 it won't
allow it error detection and data
validation to identify errors in data
transmission security measures such as
data loss prevention access control
because you don't want anyone to access
that data so with privileges and
permissions you can very carefully allow
only certain people access to that data
and you may be able to have view only
control for those people that never need
to have access to audit the data or
change it and then also data encryption
not only during transcription if you're
using a cloud hosted solution but also
while the data's at rest
now let's take a look at the different
types of data that can be generated
there's raw data that comes off an
instrument before it's processed or
undergoes any types of calculations
there's metadata contextual information
that's required to understand the data
units of measure the date and time
stamps the user ID the instrument ID as
well as audit trails
all right let's talk a little bit more
about audit Trails audit trails are a
history of that sample so basically it's
the who what when why where so if a
validated and approved result has been
audited that analysts needs to record a
reason for the change so it records the
date the time of the original sample and
the user ID the date and time of the new
sample the user ID the instrument ID
possibly along with the facility that it
was changed with and most importantly a
reason for the change
next let's take a look at some data
Handling Systems there's the limbs
laboratory information management system
that can manage all the information
generated within the laboratory along
with all of the
metadata the
reagents supplies chemicals used in the
laboratory the employee training record
information the instrument maintenance
repair
calibration information all the
information about the sample and then
there's the CDs systems that collect all
the data from the instruments whether
it's hplc or GC and then a data
management system which can be any
system in the organization that manages
data throughout part or all of the
sample life cycle most organizations
will have a variety of systems in place
to ensure data quality
now let's take a quick look at
compliance
21cfr part 11 deals with electronic
records and electronic signatures
and it covers everything from data text
Graphics audio or anything that's stored
in a digital form electronic signatures
are legally binding and equivalent to
handwritten signatures and along with
this laboratory should have a written
standard operating procedure in place
that describes how analysts should
manage and maintain their user
credentials so their username and
password it's important that these not
be shared that they're not written down
on Post-it notes and placed on their
computer so it's important that that
documentation is in place as well
predictive rules are also covered under
compliance the FDA regulations require
that data records are to be maintained
or submitted for compliance to the FDA
cgmp current good manufacturing
practices should be followed and they're
defined in 21 CFR Parts 210 211 and 212
and then GXP is a general term that
refers to good practices in a variety of
fields including manufacturing
laboratory and clinical
now if we look at compliance a little
bit more there are technical controls
instrument Hardware features that
control access with usernames and
passwords and permissions their software
user authentication and authorization
there's procedural control so Sops who
is trained on the SOP is able to execute
it rules for practice within the scope
of work and then also standard operating
procedures so these are written
instructions that can be linked in the
instrument controller or in the limbs so
that someone can call them up as they're
executing the experiment so it's they're
they're just work instructions
next we're going to take a look at the
compliance of the hardware and the
software the IQ the oq and the PQ the IQ
is the installation qualification and
it's basically documentation that states
that the software was installed on the
hardware according to the vendor's
instructions and that it's been verified
and validated next is the oq or the
operational qualification this is
basically the verification and
validation of the hardware software to
perform as promised by the vendor and
finally there's the PQ or the
performance qualification this is
documented testing and validation of the
human performance of the analytical test
upon the hardware and software this is
often completed by the laboratory team
or a third party validation expert
now this slide basically shows a few of
the controls in place that help to
promote and enforce data Integrity we
talked about the IQ oqpq the
laboratory's quality manual document
control system for author review and
approval product audit trails that
require a reason if there is an audit
that is Bond a customer Audits and the
findings of those audits active
directory to ensure that there's
secure login validation package with
reports and risk assessments and these
can be generated within the laboratory
or a third-party firm that specializes
in validating commercial software
Microsoft team Foundation server with
Version Control for any code that's been
added and this is all enforcing
electronic signatures as well as gamp5
now we've talked about failures in data
Integrity now let's take a look at some
FDA enforcement actions that can occur
first there can be a warning letter that
can be sent to individuals or firms
notifying them of specific violations
and Advising correction then there could
be a seizure a removal of the goods from
Commerce we see this with product
recalls whether it be in the food or
pharmaceutical industry
oftentimes you'll see some for
over-the-counter drugs there can be an
injunction a court order to commence a
refrain from doing a specific act or
prevent violations from occurring and
there can also be criminal prosecution
next we're going to take a look at a few
case studies and see what occurs
when there isn't a culture of data
integrity
we'll examine the government covid test
kit failures
I chose this example because I felt that
this is something that everyone's
familiar with and would be interested in
learning more about
the CDC was under a lot of pressure to
create a rapid test kit for covid-19
other countries had created them Germany
China South Korea the sequence
information of the
coronavirus was published so this
information was available the CDC
decided that instead of having a single
test against a single Target which is
covid-19 they wanted to have a single
test with multiple targets they wanted
to differentiate covid-19 from Cyrus COV
and this decision caused a lot of
heartburn down the road
the CDC was under a lot of pressure to
release the test kits and they had
multiple targets so when they were
creating the kits
the kits were actually made in multiple
Laboratories by different people and
there was poor communication among those
people and it was later determined there
was a lack of training as well and not a
lot of experience in manufacturing so
they soon discovered that with the kits
that were sent out to you know hundreds
of Public Health Facilities across the
United States that there were problems
soon these problems were reported by the
media the New York Times along with many
other media outlets and people started
learning about failures of the test kit
when the FDA investigated they found out
that the negative control of the PCR
test kit created by the CDC was
contaminated and this resulted in false
positive so people who were positive for
covid tested positive and people who
were negative for covid tested positive
the FDA had rules in place initially to
prevent any other laboratory other than
the CDC from making
the covid-19 test so at the end of
February they lifted that restriction
and let other Laboratories manufacture
the covid test kit because there was a
huge backlog and demand for those kids
next we're going to examine rejected
nasal swabs as part of the covid
sampling kit by the Canadian government
due to mold contamination
the central Canadian government
determined that nasal swabs to be used
in the covid-19 test kits were
contaminated with mold this was very
disturbing because above all you don't
want to do any harm to patients and this
could have really caused a lot of
problems for patients coming in for
testing so the contaminated test kits
were destroyed they later found that
there were more contaminated test kits
as they started investigating
the Canadian news media started
reporting on other contaminated swabs
there are also reports of contaminated
ppes The Mask as well so there was you
know a lot of problems with mold and
there were also other reports of
contamination with bacteria so hopefully
you can understand the importance of
data integrity and testing and making
sure that there's a sound quality
management system in place
the impacts of bad data are staggering
first and most important loss of life
in any outbreak it's critical to
identify those people who are infected
from those who are not and making sure
you can isolate and quarantine them
Financial losses in the billions
political outfall loss of reputation and
loss of trust in the Health Care system
so it's really important to ensure that
Laboratories are testing the testing is
being communicated and that the data
that's being generated has high data
integrity
finally we'll look at the vaccine
development challenges by the
pharmaceutical companies that all relate
to product quality
it became apparent very early on that
there were problems when the vaccine for
covid-19 was being manufactured there's
a plant in Baltimore that had repeated
articles written about quality issues
the Baltimore facility was manufacturing
vaccines for several different
pharmaceutical companies AstraZeneca and
Johnson and Johnson were among them and
they found that there was contamination
problems and many doses had to be
discarded into the Millions
and in the case of Johnson and Johnson
production they actually had to Halt
production this was the FDA action they
had up to 15 million doses that needed
to be discarded because they weren't
sure of the quality and they had
contamination fears there were problems
with their disinfection practices the
size and design of the facility handling
of the raw materials training of workers
one report that I read said that the FDA
stopped documenting violations because
there were so many
now when you when you hear about all
these cases of violations of data
Integrity that does not build trust if
you look at other examples of data
Integrity failures and these were just
pulled from reviewing public FDA reports
there are things such as files being
saved to a personal computer or a jump
drive not saved on the network sharing
of passwords to save money on software
licenses or just poor practices
disabling the audit Trail so that
results could be modified without there
being any trace of it
hpl integration parameters were changed
and rerun with the results passing No
Electronic backup of data unsanctioned
sample testing with labels such as demo
blank or trial
inadequate access to controls roles and
privileges so software wasn't properly
configured so that everyone could have
access to all the data users would log
in with a shared account and change data
so no one could trace who the exact user
was so these are just a few of the
findings
there are many many more I just wanted
to highlight some examples next we're
going to examine a few data Integrity
issues that deal with raw data so raw
data is data for things such as sample
weights the preparation of Standards or
controls that are used in the analysis
of a sample you want to make sure
there's full traceability so that you
know the lot number the expiration date
the volume that is left in that
container also you want to try to avoid
the excessive use of excel sheets for
storing this information just because
anyone can access them and you can also
change data either on accident or
maliciously and there's no audit Trail
you want to make sure that there's no
missing data or duplicate data so you
may not know which is the right answer
we've seen cases of people shredding
data during FDA Audits and then also
having data on paper logbooks which can
be destroyed or stolen so really
important to maintain that traceability
trail from all of the components and raw
data from the instruments from the
reagents to supplies in the laboratory
as well as maintaining that certificate
of analysis that's basically verifying
that that reagent or standard or Supply
is
has been tested and is ready for use
okay now we've spent a few slides
looking at failures now let's take a
look at how we can promote data
Integrity in an organization we can do
this by executing risk-based validation
making sure that everyone that the
laboratory by supplies and reagents from
is on ISO certified laboratory making
sure that the laboratory has clear
sop standard operating procedures that
everyone has been trained on and the
training has been documented and if
there have been any tests that have been
associated with that training they're
also stored in the limbs making sure
that audit trails are in place and those
other Trails can generate an audit
report taking a look at change control
so that if something is modified there
if there may be retraining required
looking at quality I.T validated systems
having a business continuity plan so if
there's a catastrophic
crash of the servers what happens is
there a backup plan are there hot
servers hot spares ready to go into
production is data located off-site
as has data Integrity training been
implemented in the organization has data
been backed up has anyone done a test of
the backup to make sure that it truly is
accessible so these are the types of
things that are promoting data integrity
now to summarize having bad data in your
organization isn't just dangerous it
could be deadly as we've seen in the few
case studies that we've looked at
automation enhances data quality it
really makes it easier because there are
electronic date and time stamps so you
don't have to record that information
manually it takes the transcription
errors out of the equation because data
is transferred electronically no one has
to manually cut and paste or re-enter
data into a solution it promotes an
environment that facilitates
data integrity and Regulatory Compliance
there's a solid audit Trail to protect
any changes to data and data security is
there in place to prevent tampering so
only those people that have access and
Privileges and permissions can access
that data I mean the cost of bad data it
can not only financially ruin an
organization but it can hurt a company's
reputation it can cause serious harm or
death for either humans or animals I'm
sure many of you have heard of the the
cases with melamine and Pet Food and
infant formula and even human food so
you know it's it's really sad when
people don't Embrace a culture of
quality because the the outcome it can
be deadly
thank you all for your time today and I
wish you all a wonderful day